hey this is presh talwalker a plot of
land with area 876 square meters was
divided into three rectangular portions
of equal width using 177 meters of fence
as shown
so we have a diagram with three
different rectangles the total width of
the rectangles is 36 meters the top
rectangle has length equal to a b the
middle rectangle has length that's less
than a b and the final rectangle has the
longest length that's equal to 27 meters
there are two parts to the question part
A find the length of a b
Part B find the perimeter of the plot of
land
I think now for the suggestion
this problem is adapted from the psle
2022 paper which was given in Singapore
to students who are approximately 12 to
13 years old this was considered the
hardest question of the exam
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
foreign
I had fun working this out so let's go
through it step by step
the three rectangular portions have
equal width we know the total width is
equal to 36 meters and each of these
three widths will be equal to each other
so each of them will be equal to 36 over
3 which is equal to 12 meters each
now we know that the total fencing was
177 meters
the bottom length is equal to 27 meters
so the other side of the rectangle will
also be equal to 27 meters now the top
length is equal to a b
so the other side of the rectangle will
also have the same length of a b
so what's the total amount of fencing
let's set up an equation we have 177
that will be equal to 36 times 2 because
we want to count both widths
then we'll add 27 times 2 because
that'll be two sides of this rectangle
plus we have a b multiplied by 2.
we've covered all the fencing so now we
just focus on this equation we have 177
is equal to 126 plus a b times 2. that
means 51 is equal to a b times 2 which
means a b is equal to 51 over 2 or 25.5
that's the answer to part A now let's
move to the second part
we know the total area is 876 square
meters
so that'll be the area of these three
rectangles
so 876 is equal to the area of the top
rectangle that's 25.5 times 12 plus the
area of the middle rectangle let's call
this length CD so we have cd times 12.
and finally we have the bottom area
so that'll be 27 times 12.
this means that 876 is equal to 306 plus
CD times 12 plus 324 that means 246 is
equal to CD times 12 so CD is equal to
20.5
so this length will be 25.5 minus 20.5
which is equal to 5 meters
here we also 20.5 so this length will be
27 minus 20.5 so this will be 6.5 meters
we now need to calculate the perimeter
of this shape
so we have 36 plus 25.5 plus 12 plus 5
plus 12 plus 6.5 plus 12 plus 27. we add
these all up and we get the perimeter is
equal to
136 meters
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
[Music]